welcome to Hannity buckle up tonight a
system-wide meltdown at our southern
border this is real now that according
to senior DHS officials they are
sounding the alarm about the very real
crisis now spiraling out of control this
very hour in a major way illegal
immigration is surging Border Patrol is
expected to make a hundred thousand
apprehensions this month alone the
majority of those taken into custody are
family units or accompanied minors one
senior official telling Fox News tonight
that the volume of migrants is
unsustainable major ports of entry are
now facing serious backlogs hundreds of
trucks delivering important cargo wait
around to be processed US border
personnel are overwhelmed tonight
cartels drug traffickers human
traffickers are now more dangerous than
ever in more danger when you think about
it putting us in more danger and get
this it's about to get worse another
massive migrant caravan is on the way
we are literally at a breaking point
which is why the president is standing
by his pledge he may have to close the
southern border completely let's take a
look Mexico I said up close I really
wanted to close it but now Mexico said
no no first time in decades we will not
let anybody get through and they've
apprehended over a thousand people today
at the at the southern border their
southern border but they don't want the
border closed and you know who else
doesn't want the border closed the
Democrats they don't want the border
closed and I agree it's going to be a
big toll but trade and commerce and
making money for a country it's all very
important but to me the most important
job I have is the security of our
country even more important than those
other things that I talked about it is
also why this weekend the president cut
off USA to three countries on this
program we have been raising serious
concerns about this very real crisis on
our southern border for years it's worse
than ever and for good reason we've all
seen the images tens of thousands
unvetted undocumented individuals
carrying flags
from different countries demanding entry
into the united states we have all seen
the data we've repeated it often
including the devastation from heroin
that's right
ninety percent of that drug pours across
that southern border responsible for
nearly 300 deaths each and every week in
this country nevermind fentanyl now
we've also heard directly from Border
Patrol personnel they're calling out
they are asking for help asking for
walls asking for more agents asking for
more security equipment even the Border
Patrol chief under President Obama who
will join us tonight he is saying this
is not a manufactured crisis a very real
emergency remember when the media mobbed
the press arm of the extreme radical
Democratic Socialist Party they were all
using the same phrase manufactured
crisis you know when you have the
Democrats and you have the media mob
using the same exact words it can't even
like separate themselves or delineate
themselves by picking different words
that's how connected they are watch this
president Ron must stop holding the
American people hostage much stop
manufacturing a crisis this president
just used the backdrop of the Oval
Office to manufacture a crisis the big
scam of the hole address was that
there's a crisis there's not a crisis
the locals will tell him on the border
even conservatives is that there isn't a
national security crisis a national
security crisis the notion that we have
a crisis there security crisis is
absolute nonsense some question if there
is a crisis at all as the president has
claimed there is not a crisis at the
border
it's a manufactured crisis for the
president to get a political lamp this
artificial crisis of the president isn't
going to justify his appropriating money
for a wall that Congress is unwilling to
give their crisis at the border the
president said there's a humanitarian
crisis at our border is there absolutely
not he's determined to convince you
there is a crisis at the border even
though and intelligence official tells
CNN quote no one is saying this is a
crisis except then drug cartels gangs
let's see in a two-year period
forth
thousand plus homicides 30,000 plus
sexual assaults all and a hundred
thousand violent assaults by illegal
immigrant criminals the 2% remember they
were always the same people spreading a
conspiracy theory about President Trump
Russia Russia Russia Russia Russia for
two years on collusion their hatred for
Trump overrides any common sense logic
or even a real national security
humanitarian emergency at our southern
border remember these countries people
in these countries are seeing this wall
being built and other areas fixed and
they're seeing this as the last
opportunity to maybe get into America
illegally so we sent our Fox News
contributor our very special contributor
Lawrence Jones down to the great border
state of Texas see what they think of
the ongoing manufactured crisis take a
look so beta work he's running for
president you're already shaking your
head at him he says that we should tear
the wall down that we already have no as
a Texas resident you don't feel like
that's reason no not at all we need to
keep the walls up if people want to come
here they can come legally I think it'd
be a huge mistake and we have to have
borders we've got to enforce the
immigration laws I do believe like they
should turn down the wall all together
leave the fencing but that's enough we
have enough border security I don't feel
like we need to build the wall we put
borders up to secure the country and
scare Texas
[Music]
you know secures the sovereignty of the
United States so I think the border is
there for a reason
I think fencing is a good idea I don't
like I think the wall has become kind of
too politicized
there's all kinds of cyber and
intelligent security of course right how
do you stop them actually from crossing
over I'm certain there's technology
that's better than a wall you feel like
there's a current crisis with the border
right now I don't watch collusion is a
little naive to say there is no issue at
all I think the borders are being
overwhelmed right now and it's it's over
taxing the citizens of Texas and so
we're taxing the citizens united states
if they don't get it together he's just
going to shut down the entire border it
does sound extreme but if it needs to be
done let's do it let's do it we will
continue to track the emergency at our
southern border very closely and show
you what other networks will not
actually report facts that's coming up
tomorrow Lawrence will be with Border
Patrol agents Laredo Texas special
segment you don't want to miss we'll
have more on that also later tonight but
first we turn to our very important
Hannity watch on the radical extreme
Democratic socialists 2020 candidates
and breaking just moments ago according
to the New York Times two more women
have now come forward to accuse creepy
crazy uncle Joe Biden of inappropriate
conduct this includes one survivor of
sexual assault who claims quote
Biden rested his hand on her thigh even
as she squirmed in her seat showing him
discomfort and according to reports
creepy crazy Uncle Joe not happy that
his cringe-worthy unsolicited multiple
public displays of affection is a big
issue now in this campaign instead of
owning up to his creepy behavior and
apologizing Biden's camp is blaming
everybody even Bernie Sanders campaign
and of course for the smears and
forgeries from the right-wing trolls but
a picture like that and so many others
speak thousands of words on their own
these images do not look good the
Sanders campaign denying that they
planted the story and whether the
Democratic
party had told us we're supposed to
believe all women no due process no
presumption of innocence anyone accused
she just sit down and shut up remember
this I believe her listen first of all
anybody who comes forward at this point
to be prepared to testify in the United
States Senate against someone who's
being nominated to one of the most
powerful positions of the United States
government that takes an extraordinary
amount of courage not only do women like
dr. Ford who bravely comes forward need
to be heard but they need to be believed
they need to be believed I just want to
say to the men in this country just shut
up and step up do the right thing let me
just say right at the outset I believe
dr. Ford I believe the survivor here I
believe her I stand with her I believe I
believe I believe well I guess that
doesn't apply to the women Biden our net
are now accusing Biden of harassing
allegedly and quite frankly really any
other Democrat one another example oh do
they believe the women that have been
accusing the Virginia lieutenant
governor just in Fairfax facing two
serious separate horrific allegations of
violence sexual assault and rape where
are all the I believe women crowd people
are they protesting in the streets of
Richmond have they demanded as firing
demanding a criminal investigation into
lieutenant governor nope
Virginia Democrats won't even hold a
bipartisan hearing for the accusers so
now these two women they are speaking
out in very powerful interviews last
night we first showed you this clip from
vanessa tyson take a look he's pushing
down and pushing down and I couldn't
know all my neck up and I didn't know
what was going on I honestly didn't know
what was going on and then the next
thing I know like my head is like
literally in his crotch the sexual
assault is an epidemic
that's taking place around the world
across our country every day what do you
want to happen - Justin Fairfax why are
you coming forward I'd want him to
resign and today the second accuse of
Meredith Watson also speaking out
telling Gayle King how Fairfax allegedly
raped her at Duke University look at
this he did things that you shouldn't do
to someone without their permission
mm-hmm and I tried several times to get
up Ben Lee even
those push back down and what happened
he forcibly sexually assaulted and raped
me and you made it clear this is not
what I want it was very clear because
you know he is saying this night was
consensual if you have to hold someone
down it's not consensual
both women telling people at the time
scary heart-wrenching accounts and the
silence is deafening lieutenant governor
is calling the incidents consensual well
here in this program we're going to be
consistent believing in due process
believing in the presumption of
innocence but we also take these
allegations very seriously by the way we
commend Gayle King for doing the same
and even the Republicans for once they
actually did something right with
Professor Ford they treated it with the
seriousness it deserved they gave a
hearing and they gave a response for
justice Cavanaugh in those hearings and
meanwhile most in the mainstream media
just totally completely content with
ignoring those serious allegations and
just hoping it goes away and with the
exception of a few good journalists I
hate Trump media mob working in
partnership once again with their
friends in the Democratic Party fake
news CNN
tinfoil hat conspiracy theory network
MSNBC others actively ignoring real
scandals real stories real evidence
about their friends in the Democratic
Party acting the exact opposite as they
would if it was a Republican
instead they spent what years pushing
collusion collusion hoax collusion
conspiracy theory with no evidence to
back it up while also simultaneously
ignoring the biggest abuse of power
corruption scandal in history this media
mob is fully prepared to give any
Democrat a free pass and will see this
all play out now in real time where are
all of you I believers where are you now
for example Elizabeth Warren she's
facing zero blowback for calling the
president of walking talking living
breathing threat to national security if
you could say anything she wants take a
look at least 25 people in this
administration had been denied security
Clarence's yeah why oh because they had
ties to foreign governments because they
had conflicts of interest because they
had financial problems that made them
vulnerable and what does the President
of the United States do instead of
saying hey whoa my responsibilities
watch out for the American people no
these are friends these are people with
money and with connections and the
answer was just ran them on through you
know the Trump administration is a
walking talking living breathing threat
to national security
really senator I think save the lectures
because you've been faking your
background for decades and take it an
advantage of something that wasn't true
walking talking living breathing
embarrassment that would be you to the
people of Massachusetts and the country
let's not forget two other serious
embarrassments of the Democratic Party
New York senator Kirsten Gillibrand is
on a quest to end the electoral college
so that means places like New York and
California they'll have more power and
so too is bado bozo O'Rourke actually
compared the Electoral College to
slavery and sadly O'Rourke is just one
of many radical Democrats running on a
platform of how do we get more power not
more power for the American people more
power for them more power for the
government more power for a few
concentrated let's see the people of
Washington New York New Jersey let's see
Illinois they're gonna get to decide
every president I don't think a lot of
states are gonna want to be participants
in that power over your wallets power
over your business they'll tell you how
to run it power over your healthcare
power over your property rights your gun
rights power over your life don't be
fooled by false promises new Green Deal
no oil no gas no combustion engine no
cars no cows no planes great plan and
everything's free the future of America
as we know it is now at stake okay it's
that serious before we get to our guests
with one more important
breaking story at this hour tonight we
are now learning according to the Daily
Caller the George Soros is back group
paid firms tied to fusion GPS and
Christopher Steele nearly four million
dollars in 2017 to provide research into
government entities that's roughly three
times with the DNC and the Clinton
campaign paid in 2016 at the outcome is
the same
collusion let's see a nine-month FBI
report to congressional investigations
and yes the Moller report definitive no
collusion a hoax